Sanktionen gegen Russland damit darüber
spreche ich jetzt mit Professor Andreas
Heinemann grüner konfliktforscher an der
Universität Bonn Herr heinemann-grüder
Sanktionen haben die jemals überhaupt
politische Konflikte wirklich gelöst
nein aber sie erhöhen natürlich den
Preis für dieses Verhalten es geht im
Moment darum Zeit zu gewinnen die
Sanktionen die werden die russische
Wirtschaft natürlich hart treffen und
möglicherweise zu elitenspaltung führen
es kann allerdings sein dass der
militärische Sieg Russlands in der
Ukraine schneller da ist als dass die
Sanktionen schmerzhafte Wirkung auf die
russische Wirtschaft und auf die
Bevölkerung haben insofern ist es ein
spiellaufzeit im Moment man hofft ja mit
Sanktionen auch eine gewisse
Unzufriedenheit in der Bevölkerung zu
erzeugen aber ist das in Russland
überhaupt möglich gelenkte Staatsmedien
eine brutale Staatsmacht die jede noch
so kleine Demonstrationen niederknüppelt
ist das realistisch
man muss das Vergleichen mit Hitler in
den letzten Monaten seiner Herrschaft
putin ist einer Art lebt in einer Art
Bunker er kümmert sich gar nicht mehr um
die eigene Bevölkerung sondern hat sich
das absolute Ziel gesetzt hier die
Ukraine unterwerfen zu können
entmilitarisieren zu können Kiew
einnehmen zu können die Regierung dort
ersetzen und einem Marionettenregierung
einsetzen zu können diese absoluten
Ziele sind für ihnen nachdem er sie auch
öffentlich erklärt hat gar nicht mehr
verhandelbar insofern kann er eigentlich
nur durch eine Art von 20 Juli 44 durch
Offiziere die ihnen umbringen
gestürzt oder gestoppt werden
solange es vom Westen keine
Militärintervention gibt kann natürlich
der Versuch unternommen werden den Preis
der der Besatzung hochzutreiben durch
Partisanenkrieg aber letztlich glaube
ich kann er nur durch
Leute aus dem Sicherheitsapparat in
Russland selber gestürzt werden die
sagen wir machen mit diesem Kamikaze
nicht mehr mit
da würde ich gern noch mal nachhaken
viele sagen ja es sind die Oligarchen
die den Einfluss aufputieren und auf die
Politik hätten und da einen Wechsel
herbeiführen können sie sagen es kann
nur aus dem Sicherheitsapparat kommen
ja also Putin hat jetzt schon mal den
Chef vom
Auslandsgeheimdienst vorgeführt
öffentlich im Fernsehen abgekanzelt das
führt natürlich zu Unzufriedenheit wenn
selbst die Chefs sozusagen der
verschiedenen Sicherheitsapparate hier
wie Höflinge behandelt werden die nur
noch Befehlsempfänger sind aber
überhaupt keine Ratschlägen mehr
übergeben können je mehr sich die
militärische Situation verschärft je
höher auch die Kosten also immer die
menschlichen Kosten für das russische
Militär werden umso mehr werden da
Stimmen laut wollen wir eigentlich ein
zweites Afghanistan
nun gab es ja die Drohung von Putin die
abschreckungswaffen der russischen Armee
in Alarmbereitschaft zu setzen dazu
gehören eben unter anderem auch die
atomschränkköpfe ist das ein
durchschaubares Manöver wie es jetzt
gerne dargestellt wird oder will man uns
damit nur beruhigen indem man sagt dass
meint er ja gar nicht so
er will vor allen Dingen den Westen
davon abhalten sich direkt militärisch
einzumischen auf der Seite der Ukraine
das heißt wenn ihr die Ukraine
militärische unterstützt dann müsst ihr
euch selber mit der Gefahr eines
Atomkrieges auseinandersetzen da ihr den
ja nicht wollt überlasst uns quasi die
Ukraine als unser Einflussgebiet also
militärische
Bündnisse wolltet ihr mit der Ukraine
schon vorher nicht warum in dieser
Situation ob er wirklich so
eskalationsbereit ist bis zum Äußersten
zu gehen ist schwer abzuschätzen weil im
Moment die Rationalität von Putin nicht
mehr überschaubar ist das heißt ob er
überhaupt noch zugänglich ist für
irgendwelche Ratschläge oder für
irgendwelche sozusagen Vito Positionen
die andere einnehmen
müsste der Westen gar nicht so wenig
militärisch beteiligt an dem Konflikt in
der Ukraine wir der Westen liefern ja
massiv jetzt Waffen in die Ukraine droht
dort ein sogenannter
Stellvertreterkrieg wie wir es aus
vielen vielen anderen Konflikten auch
gar kennen in den vergangenen Jahren und
Jahrzehnten
ich weiß nicht wer hier wen
stellvertretend sozusagen vorschickt wir
führen ja hier keinen Krieg gegen
Russland mit dem Stellvertreter Ukraine
sondern die Ukraine verteidigt ihre
eigene territoriale Integrität und
Souveränität gegen einen Nachbarstaat
der behauptet dass das sein eigenes
Einflussgebiet ist und dass er sich von
dem Territorium des anderen sozusagen
einverleiben kann was er haben möchte
gucken sich die Karte schon der von den
Russen eingenommenen Gebiete an die
Wahrscheinlichkeit dass Russland das je
wieder abgeben wird also weit über den
Donbass hinaus ist relativ gering die
Landbrücke zum
transnistin Moldawien die wird
vielleicht in den nächsten Tagen
geschlossen
ich würde gerne noch mal auf die
Waffenlieferung eingehen die gehen ja
möglicherweise auch so gibt es zumindest
Meldungen über Polen in direkt zumindest
liegt ja auch nah es gibt eine große
gemeinsame Grenze dort außerdem ist das
Gebiet zur polnischen Grenze ja nicht
von Russland kontrolliert droht da an
dieser Stelle dann einen überschwappen
des Konfliktes in nato-bereiche
das kann sein und kann auch nicht
ausgeschlossen werden was ich für sehr
wahrscheinlich halte ist dass Julian
Szenario die Russen haben erst gedacht
sie könnten innerhalb einer kurzen Phase
von vielleicht drei vier Tagen die
Ukraine überrollen die würden dann
aufgeben und würden die als Befreier
begrüßen und jetzt werden wir sehen wie
in Aleppo und Homs haben das heißt die
Bombardierung von Städten wer nicht
innerhalb von kürzester Zeit sozusagen
die sogenannten humanitären Korridore
raus aus Kiew zum Beispiel wahrnimmt der
gilt dann als Freiwild als Terrorist als
Extremist und es damit für russischen
Abschluss freigegeben wir sollten uns
die Fotos noch mal von Aleppo und homes
angucken dann wissen wir was wir den
nächsten Tagen bekommen Herr
heinemann-grüder wir haben es gerade
eben gehört
partisanenkämpfe ein Untergrund Krieg
ist das wahrscheinlich ein
wahrscheinliches Szenario für die
Ukraine
also wenn die Stadt eingeschlossen wird
dann werden wir eine Art von leningrada
Blockade dort erleben so wie die Nazis
versucht haben die Stadt Leningrad im
Zweiten Weltkrieg auszuhungern diese
Technik wird dann da für den Russen
selbst angewandt das heißt die werden
abgeschnitten sein von der Versorgung
die werden zu einem ausgehungert das
wird also zu einer
humanitären Großkatastrophe führen die
werden versuchen den Strom abzustellen
die Wasserzufuhr abzustellen man wird da
von den eisernen Reserven Leben und
irgendwann hoffen dass die dann aufgeben
die Frage ist dann kann die
internationale Gemeinschaft irgendetwas
noch tun um die dort in Kiew
Eingeschlossenen zu versorgen
einige werden dann versuchen
rauszukommen aber letztlich wird dieses
Szenario wahrscheinlicher ich habe schon
erwähnt die Russen haben mit iClip in
Syrien und mit Aleppo und Toms schon
sozusagen die Rollenmodelle für das
geliefert was jetzt auf Kiew zukommt man
sollte sich da keine Illusionen darüber
machen die Russen haben überhaupt keine
Bedenken Kriegsverbrechen zu verüben das
geht Ihnen hier um den absoluten Sieg es
geht nicht mehr um verhandlungsfrieden
und das mitten in Europa gibt es einen
Moment wird es einen Moment geben wo
dann doch überlegt wird dort
einzuschreiten in der Ukraine oder ist
das strikt ausgeschlossen aus ihrer
Sicht von jetzt einschreiten vom Westen
her
ja also
es gibt ja jetzt offensichtlich schon
versuche auch
internationale Brigaden aufzustellen
sowas hat 36 bis 39 in Spanien gegeben
gegen Franco da haben dann auch Kämpfer
sozusagen gegen das Franco Regime
gekämpft hat sie im ehemaligen
Jugoslawien und
2014/15 auch gegeben dass aus der
Westeuropa oder anderen auch
außereuropäischen Staaten kompatanten
auf der Seite sowohl der Russen wie der
Ukraine gekämpft haben also insofern
kann da eine Internationalisierung
zustande kommen ob jetzt einzelne
NATO-Staaten dann auch sagen wir können
nicht zugucken
wir beteiligen uns ich halte das nicht
viel vollkommen ausgeschlossen dass wir
an so ein Punkt kommen und dann wäre der
Bündnisfall gegeben weil dann Russland
möglicherweise auch gegen die
NATO-Staaten die eigene Truppen
entsenden vorgeht
sie haben gesagt einzelne Staaten
schauen wir überhaupt mal auf die
Einigkeit des Westens vielleicht erstmal
auf NATO Ebene bei beispielsweise geht
es ja jetzt auch und um
Waffenlieferungen an die Ukraine und da
hat Ungarn jetzt gesagt nee über unser
Territorium möchten wir keine
todbringenden Waffen die verlassen ist
das schon mal der Anfang der Einigkeit
oder der Anfang vom Ende der Einigkeit
das würde ich jetzt nicht sagen also
Ungarn hat in den letzten vier Wochen
außerordentlich lavierend sich verhalten
aber es gab vor einigen Tagen das
Treffen der neuen osteuropäischen
NATO-Mitglieder die haben nur ein hohes
Maß an Einigkeit gezeigt aber
wahrscheinlich gibt es in Ungarn die
Befürchtung dass
wenn sie sich militärisch daran
beteiligen sie selbst auch zum
Kriegszielen werden werden aber Rumänien
ist noch da und Polen ist noch da also
da gibt es noch lange Grenzen über die
auch Waffen Nachschub aus NATO starten
möglich ist
militärisch gibt es ja auch noch mal
zwei Staaten die bisher Neutralität
immer wieder bewiesen haben das sind
Finnland und Schweden Finnland hat sich
ja jetzt davon gelöst und hat gesagt wir
liefern Waffen in die Ukraine wird da
eine Erweiterung des NATO-Bündnisses
nach Norden mit einmal möglich
das ist möglich
natürlich haben die finden da auch
aufgrund des winterkrieges 1939 40
Befürchtungen dass sie vielleicht die
nächsten sind wir wissen ja nicht wann
wo Putin aufhört aber das ist jetzt
erstmal Zukunftsmusik Moment geht es
darum die nächsten Tage und Wochen zu
überleben weil wenn Putin sozusagen mit
einem Siegfrieden einem militärischen
aus der Situation hervorgeht dann wird
das uns auf Jahre insbesondere auch die
Ukraine beschäftigen wir haben jetzt
immer viel auf Europa geschaut aber
Global Player sind auch außerhalb von
Europa und da darf man ja nicht
vergessen zum Beispiel die Türkei die
hat ja jetzt die Durchfahrt ins Schwarze
Meer für Kriegsschiffe untersagt ist das
ein entscheidender Schritt der Türkei in
Richtung Europa wird sich da etwas
ändern
das ist nicht unbedingt ein Schritt der
Türkei in Richtung Europa aber es ist
klar dass die Türkei ja schon bei dem
Krieg um nagornikarabach Armenien 2020
deutlich gemacht hat wie überlassen den
Post sowjetischen Raum nicht mehr den
Russen und sie positionieren sich hier
als eine Macht die eigene Interessen
auch im Post sowjetischen Raum wahrnimmt
und nicht mehr neutral ist sondern sich
auch schon zuvor auf die Seite der
Ukraine gestellt hat und natürlich sind
die Drohnen die die Türkei an die
Ukraine liefern kann eine sehr wirksame
Waffe die vor der die russischen Truppen
höchsten Respekt haben würden das hat
sich schon in Armenien gezeigt
ja zwischendurch noch mal ein kleiner
Hinweis auf die aktuelle politische
Situation eigentlich für diese Minuten
war ein Statement des
Außenministers Russlands lavrov vor dem
Menschenrechtsrat in Genf der ja gerade
in dieser Woche seine Frühjahrstagung
abhält erwartet worden es ist unklar ob
das tatsächlich stattfindet dieses
Statement auf jeden Fall wird lavrov
nicht persönlich dort anreisen er hatte
schon erklärt wegen des Flugverbots
hätte er keine Möglichkeit nach Genf zu
kommen vielleicht gibt es eine
Videobotschaft das würden sie dann hier
gleich auch bei Phoenix live sehen und
Boris Johnson ist in die nach Polen und
auch ins Baltikum aufgebrochen führt
dort Gespräche und wird dann auch eine
Pressekonferenz heute abhalten gegen
10:30 Uhr 11 Uhr da werden wir natürlich
live für sie berichten das nur mal kurz
einige wichtige Informationen aus einem
Tag der sich wie alle anderen Tage in
diesem Krieg
weiterentwickelt ja ich bespreche noch
mit Andreas Heinemann grüner er ist
Konflikt forscher an der Universität
Bonn wir hatten gerade schon mal über
die Rolle der Türkei gesprochen jetzt
möchte ich noch mal ganz nach Osten
gehen und eine Rolle verstehe ich nicht
aber vielleicht können Sie mir das als
konfliktforscher erklären was ist die
Rolle Chinas in diesem Konflikt
china hat ja im UN-Sicherheitsrat nicht
für Russland gestimmt das heißt also es
gab eine Resolution und da haben sich
die Chinesen enthalten das ist das erste
Zeichen dafür dass China eigentlich von
der Allianz mit Putin abrückt sie haben
auch kein Interesse daran
Separatismus militärisch zu unterstützen
weil sie das befürchten für China selbst
die u-gebühren könnten sich ja dann
abspalten wenn das Beispiel der Russen
in der Ukraine sozusagen international
Schule macht also china ist ein
schlüsselplayer dafür auch international
Russland sozusagen einzuheben wenn ich
jetzt Diplomat wäre dann würde ich sehr
starke Initiativen in Richtung Peking
starten und sagen tut alles was ihr
könnt um Putin zu stoppen
möchte mal auf das Thema Sanktionen
eingehen weltweit aber auch von der EU
momentan geht es eine große Einigkeit
alle Länder in Europa machen mit aber
Annalena baerbock hat es ja auch im
Bundestag gesagt am Sonntag wir Deutsche
aber auch in der EU wir brauchen einen
langen Atem aus den Erfahrungen anderer
Konflikte glauben sie dass wir diesen
langen Atem tatsächlich haben weil wie
oft sind nicht Sanktionen einfach
entweder unterlaufen worden mit der Zeit
oder einfach dann vernachlässigt worden
die Sanktionen in der Vergangenheit
waren ja eher symbolischer Natur das
heißt sie durften uns selber nicht
treffen das heißt es wurden nur solche
Sanktionen
verhängt die die
letztliche
symbolischen Charakter hatten wenn Putin
jetzt nicht mehr in Monaco Urlaub machen
kann das hat er ohnehin nicht vor aber
jetzt trifft es den Bankensektor jetzt
trifft es den Energiesektor jetzt trifft
es die Oligarchen jetzt trifft es
sozusagen die russische
Luftfahrtindustrie jetzt trifft das den
Technologietransfer das sind alles
Wirkungen die sozusagen strategisch
einwirken ich glaube nicht dass
angesichts dieses Krieges auf absehbare
Zeit die EU wieder den Rückwärtsgang
einlegt und sie davon abrücken
das war eine Einschätzung von Andreas
Heinemann grüner zum Konflikt zum Krieg
Russland gegen die Ukraine und die
ganzen Folgen Sanktionen und aber auch
die politische weitere mögliche
Entwicklung herzlichen Dank erstmal
soweit für das Gespräch